all right i think we've got brent here
with us now brent how are you
i'm good how are you doing i'm doing
fantastic i'm very excited to talk to
you i think the first time i talked to
you uh on the podcast was back in 2020
and you had uh coined the milk the
dollar milkshake theory and at the time
i remember saying to myself well the one
thing that i'm for sure is that that's
great marketing because i'll never
forget that name uh and maybe what we
could do to kind of start the
conversation is just help people
understand like the high level like what
is this dollar milkshake theory then we
get into kind of what's happened over
the last two years
sure
so in very simple terms and kind of the
reason i came up with the whole
description of the of the thesis as the
milkshake theory was i wanted to kind of
come up with just a really simple way to
explain it to people
and essentially what i think has
happened since the global financial
crisis in 2008 and you could probably
actually take it back even further than
that is that
the global central banks monetary
authorities governments however you want
to define the
the people that kind of run the world
for lack of a better world have have
flooded the market with liquidity um
whether through qe or stimulus programs
or fiscal spending
and
you know once we kind of got
into that kind of 10 years into that
kind of 2018 2019
i thought we were set up for a global
sovereign currency crisis and sovereign
debt crisis
and i thought what would happen was that
all of that liquidity that had been you
know pushed into the global financial
system for lack of a better word would
be sucked up into the united states and
into the u.s dollar
and so um
i used kind of this analogy from this
this movie
um there will be blood where this oil
baron is uh you know negotiating with
the the guy that owns the land right
next to him and the guy's trying to sell
him his land and he says i don't need to
buy your land all i got to do is stick a
straw down into the ground and i can
drink your milkshake um and that's kind
of what i think is going to happen
uh it's not so important who produces
the qe what's more important is who
captures it and if you look over the
last couple years the united states
markets and the dollar itself is
captured uh i would say the most of the
global growth
um you know the dollar has risen versus
a number of global currencies despite
all the efforts to keep it down and so
that's that is in essence the milkshake
theory so i think there's a really good
framework to kind of think about this
there's who creates the qe and then who
captures the qe and maybe we can talk
about uh creation first uh it seems like
once the pandemic occurred uh and you
and i were talking originally uh every
central bank in the world basically
raced to try to have some sort of
control to inject liquidity into the
market it almost felt like they were
racing to see who could devalue their
currencies faster uh at one point and so
when you think about the creation of qe
maybe give us kind of a post analysis on
what's occurred over the last two years
around the world has it all been
generally at the same rate do you think
that there's some differences on a
geographic basis or how do you evaluate
like the creation of qe now that we're
kind of two years after the pandemic
started
well i guess there's a couple different
ways you could look at it you can look
at the you know the the central bank
balance sheet as a percentage of gdp uh
you can just look at it in total value
um you can look at it as a percent how
much how much has been put on the
central bank balance sheet that is a
percent of all outstanding treasury
issuance or or sovereign issuance
and you know i think
to your point coming right out of uh you
know the coveted response i think the
u.s was the most aggressive and did the
most initially um but i think as we got
into it it became it became clear that
while the u.s was
seemingly the most aggressive and i
would agree that they initially were
that everybody else had to do it as well
and the the big
difference the big difference is that
and if you again if i take it back if
you look at the the amount of bonds that
the u.s bought as a percentage of all
outstanding u.s treasuries
and then you compare that to other
countries the us is far and away the the
least offender or or it has done the
lowest amount so again
while the the us has done an incredible
amount they've done a lot less than the
rest of the world if you measure it that
way
the other thing uh or you can also do it
look at it as a percent of m2 how much
uh
did n2 grow well
the problem with
using domestic m2
and then comparing it to other countries
domestic into
is that
every other country quote-unquote prints
for their own domestic economy
but the u.s prince for the entire world
because the u.s is the global reserve
currency
and there is a bigger dollar market that
exists outside the united states than
exists inside the united states and
there is no entity that sits outside the
united states that can create dollars or
provide dollar liquidity
um to help that market outside the
united states when it needs it so when
the u.s and this is why i was this is
why i have said on several occasions
and i kind of said it jokingly but i'm
actually serious is the more they print
the more the fed prints
the higher the dollar will actually go
versus its peers because it will force
every other currency to do the same
thing
and that's kind of what we've seen um
you know for for the first call it's six
months to a year after covid the dollar
fell went from like 102 to 90 89 or 88
or i don't remember exactly where it
went to but it fell 10 or 12 let's call
it
and uh you know a lot of people were
saying this is the the dollar's on its
deathbed it's going to 85 it's going to
80. it's going to 75 and
my my point all the time was that unless
they completely designed redesigned the
system we're going to end up right back
where we were on march 20th um because
during that year when the dollar went
from 102 to 1 to 90 or 89 or whatever it
was
the rest of the world did not use that
time of dollar weakness to get out from
underneath their dollar loans and their
their their their need for the dollar
they actually increased their need for
the dollar because they issued
more new dollars more more funding in
dollars than they did in any other
currency
so they actually became more dependent
on the dollar
over the last two years than than than
using it to get out from underneath the
pressure of the dollar
and so that's why we're essentially back
to where we are
if you think everybody
is going to have to provide supply and
let's just say they provide it in
relatively the same rate now there's
there's obviously differences but
let's just say that they all do it at
the same rate
then the argument comes down to demand
if supply is the same then it comes down
to demand everything in economics
ultimately comes down to supply and
demand and there is just much greater
demand for dollars on a global basis
than there is for yen or euro or real or
australian dollars or yuan or you know
well whatever currency you want to pick
there is more demand globally for a
dollar than there is for any other
currency so if supply is equal it comes
down to demand and the demand just
swamps you you think that the the u.s
has provided a lot of stimulus and a lot
of new money but the demand has just
swamped it and and that's kind of where
we're at today the dollar is kind of
back to to the levels it was uh
postcoded or i mean sorry just right
right at the the height of code yeah
this is such a fascinating point talk to
me about when the fed is actually
creating uh more money right and they're
injecting all this liquidity walk people
through uh the relationship as to why
that forces other central banks to do
the same thing because i think that's
kind of a key piece to this that people
may not understand is that the fed uh
may take an action and then that forces
the hand of other central banks and what
i immediately think of is uh in the
reverse situation the fed says hey we're
gonna start tightening we saw the ecb
recently kind of capitulate on their
negative interest rate strategy they
saying hey now they're gonna start to
actually raise and kind of move and
locks up with the fed so talk about that
relationship between the fed's actions
and then other central banks around the
world
okay so it doesn't happen right away and
you know it
the fed could start easing
and
they could maybe do that for three
months six months nine months without
everybody else having to do it or maybe
without having to do it at the same rate
but if that happens
then the dollar becomes a lot weaker
right
well if the dollar becomes a lot weaker
then their currencies become a lot
stronger
the problem is is that the us is an
importing nation and those other
countries are exporting nations and it
becomes harder for them their goods
become less competitive as they become
more expensive so as their currency
appreciates
um
it becomes harder for them to to compete
with another country that maybe their
currency is strengthening against
um so so that's part of it and because
the whole world is in basically the same
situation because there's not much
global growth going on and because
everybody has borrowed more money than
they can ever possibly
um
ever possibly repay they've got funding
pressures
and so
as their economy's slow they end up
having to do their own form of fiscal
stimulus or qe
or you know stimulus however you want to
define them maybe they just cut interest
rates uh you know
but but ultimately they end up having to
match what the us is doing um
and again it has it also has to do with
the fact that while the the dollar was
weakening
they didn't use that opportunity to pay
off their dollar debt they took out even
more dollar debt
which took
which again as i said earlier increased
demand for dollars and so once everybody
else starts printing again to try to
catch up with the us you end up right
back where you are now
i'm of the belief that we're headed
towards this sovereign crisis because i
believe that the dollar going higher
causes the world problems whereas the
dollar going lower actually perpetuates
the system that we currently have
um and so as as we move forward in that
i think the rest of the world is going
to be forced
to to print
you know for lack of a better word their
their currency more than those and i'll
give you this the reason this is such a
problem
the reason it's such a problem is
because now we have because of
everything that happened after cova now
we have inflationary pressures
extraordinary inflationary pressures
which makes it harder for
those governments and those monetary
authorities to go back to easing because
if they go back to easing that increases
the inflationary pressures rather than
softens them and so
this is the environment
in which hyperinflation can occur now
i'm going to stop right there and say
that i think hyperinflation term is
grossly overused
and it's used so often in use so
incorrectly it's kind of lost its
meaning
but hyperinflation is completely and
utterly different than high inflation
hyperinflation is when
the currency loses all value and it
takes you know a thousand dollars to buy
an egg or something like that that's
hyperinflation or it's like when it's
like 60
inflation month after month after month
it's not 16 it's not 11 again there are
two completely different worlds but
this is the environment in which
hyperinflation can occur
the second thing i'm going to say is
this is not with regards to the dollar
because the u.s can print its own
currency as we've already discussed but
there is incredible demand
for that currency not just domestically
but outside the outside the united
states there's incredible demand for the
dollars now you might not like that but
that is a fact of life and the sooner
you accept it the better off you're
going to be
now that is that's not to say now here
here's let me just finish this point and
then and also this is not the same for
turkey this is not the same for
australia it's not the same for russia
or china or anywhere else for that
matter you do not need rubles
in south america now you might say that
now you need them to buy oil but you
don't need them to the same extent that
you need the dollar you don't need
australian dollars in singapore you know
you don't need brazilian real in canada
but you do need dollars in all of those
places and so what happens is now that
the dollar is higher
and since all of these other countries
have dollar funding needs and dollar
needs for trading the the the invoices
that take place in dollars they have the
worst of all worlds because global
growth is coming down so their top line
revenue is falling their funding costs
are rising
inflationary pressures are high and the
the inputs energy food um other
important commodities are priced in
dollars so their bottom line is rising
their top line is getting squeezed their
profits are falling and when that
happens what do they have to resort to
to get more dollars they have to print
their own currency
to go by the dollars to get these
important imports or these important
inputs into their businesses and so if
you have a situation where there's
incredible
demand for dollars outside your country
but no demand for your own currency
outside your country and you have to
print in order to get dollars
that is how hyperinflation takes place
so anyway i think that we're headed
there for other countries i think the
u.s would be the last place that that
happens so my question was going to be
around uh i agree with you that
hyperinflation is a term that gets
thrown around and you know there's a lot
of people who think 10 inflation a year
would be hyperinflation it's not right
and so it's uh one i think it's
important i don't think you myself
anyone else is cheering that on that's a
very very bad situation and there's a
lot of people who get hurt as we've seen
in country after country that's
experienced it it's the worst it's the
worst it is your thought process and i
think i'm hearing you say this is
basically the countries that have the
weakest currencies that's where this
occurs first and it almost kind of like
eats up the stack of the strength of
currencies and so it starts with the
weakest and eventually gets to
i don't know 50 of currencies like how
how i guess pervasive could something
like this really become around the world
well so this i think it can become very
pervasive and i think that's why we're
going to have a crisis is i think it's
it's i don't think it's just going to
happen in one or two places
and because we are no longer kind of
moving towards globalization and we're
kind of moving towards deglobalization
and we're moving towards two supply
chains and we're moving towards a
scenario where the world is fractured as
opposed to working together
um i i think it's it's it's more likely
to have contagion um where you know so
for the last two or three years when
something kind of bubbled up in one
country it just kind of stayed in that
one country because the world was kind
of cooperating everybody was doing the
same thing everybody was providing
stimulus everybody was doing qe and so
it kind of worked together just to kick
the can down the road but because we're
no longer working together because we're
no longer cooperating because we've got
this fracturing global economy i don't
think the world was going to be as quick
to work together
uh and the country i think there will be
certain countries that work together and
they'll work against other countries so
i think the likelihood of contagion
happening is much higher and so i think
to your point it'll start in the weaker
countries and then it'll bubble up to
the medium countries and then the bigger
countries
but i you know i'll point out that this
is not uh
just just i'll give a couple of examples
it's not you know we've seen it in sri
lanka i mean they're having incredible
problems you know we've seen it in
turkey um we've seen it in argentina a
number of times before right
but this year where we are seeing again
not hyperinflation but just
where this phenomenon is playing out is
in the euro and the yen
um the yen is down like 20 percent
something like that year to date now
that's that's incredible i mean it's one
of the biggest currencies in the world
maybe the second or third biggest
currency in the world and they're down
dramatically because
they have so much debt that they cannot
possibly let interest rates rise if
interest rates rise their banks
insurance companies pension funds that
have bought all of these japanese either
zero yielding or negative yielding
treasuries
if interest rates even rise one percent
it bankrupts you know the entire
japanese system so they can't let
interest rates rise so they have to go
out and buy as many bonds as possible to
keep interest rates low and when they do
that they provide more yen to the market
and so you've got this situation where
you know there's not a lot of demand for
yen outside of japan
but and they're having to provide an
incredible amount again inside japan in
order to to combat this rising interest
rates and so you have
the yen has broken this 40-year support
line and it's a big deal it's a very big
deal because now it's having knock-on
effects for some other asian currencies
the hong kong dollar is now under
pressure um their hong kong monetary
authority has had to come out for the
first time in several years and actually
buy hong kong dollars in order to
support the price
china has had to
institute massive uh you know stimulus
in order to combat the deflationary
pressures that they're having inside
their their economy and as a result the
yuan is now starting to weaken
um
and and the the fact that u.s treasuries
now ish now yield
as much as a chinese treasury uh there's
not as much flight into china to buy a
treasury with a higher yield in the us
and so money's actually leaving china
so again we've we've got this perfect
setup
for this crisis now
anthony maybe it'll never come you know
i
i can be wrong of course i can be wrong
may you know the these these uh
these government officials are amazing
at being able to kick the can down the
road
i my point has always been that
if i'm even a little bit right which i'm
not going to be 100 right it just ain't
going to happen but if i'm even a little
bit right the consequences are extremely
dire so i don't have the luxury of
ignoring it
and so far it seems to be playing out as
i expect now it's taking longer to do it
and that's typically how these things go
it's and i think it might take another
four five six years for it to fully play
out i don't think this is necessarily
going to be over by august or september
um could be you got to be ready for it
but uh but but but you know all of these
uh
these things that i've been thinking
about are kind of starting to show up
and they're showing up in very important
places
how exactly would a sovereign crisis
play out or like what does that from
like a sequential standpoint how does
that play out and what happens in that
scenario
could you repeat that i just lost you
for some reason i'm not sure what
happened but i didn't hear you
how does a sovereign crisis actually
play out like what does that look like
and what happens from like an order of
operations or like a sequence that if it
started to occur people would experience
or see this
well let's use uh let's use japan well
let's see
let's use turkey as an example because
because turkey's a smaller country it's
harder to see this playing out in japan
even though it already is starting to
um
but turkey
is an economy that has has borrowed a
lot of money in dollars so they need a
lot of dollars to service the dollar
debt that they have
in addition turkey imports 98 of their
energy and a huge percentage of their
food well energy is priced in dollars
and food imports are priced in dollars
so they have an incredible amount of
demand
um four dollars from turkey
but again there's not a lot of demand
for turkish lira in morocco right or in
the united states or in brazil so what
they have had to do is they've had to
print a lot of
lyra to to combat these pressures
the inflate the official inflation rate
in turkey is like 65 or 70 percent so if
the official inflation rate is 65 or 70
is probably double that in real life
right
um and so that that's how this is how
you start to see it playing out now what
has happened in turkey to combat this
well they've instituted a number of
capital controls so that's one signal
that you would see the other thing is
they would uh you would start to see
social unrest because it's not fun for
people people people typically don't
revolt
when they're warm and their bellies are
full they typically revolt when they're
cold and hungry right and so if you look
back throughout history you have very
rarely seen a revolution certainly not a
successful revolution
when inflation wasn't a big part of it i
mean they just kind of go hand in hand
so if you start to see a social unrest
you know
sri lanka right there's massive social
unrest because inflation has gotten so
high but you can start to see that uh
yeah we've seen that several times over
the last couple years in turkey we could
easily see that happen again uh the
other thing that you would see is you
would see start to see the leaders of
the company come out and say
incredibly uh ridiculous things that
could never actually happen
you know and so like one thing like
erdogan erdogan is the the head of uh of
turkey's the
prime minister the president of turkey
and he's also kind of the de facto head
of the central bank
well when everybody started taking their
money out
of the their dollars out of the the
turkish banking system you know he
basically stopped them from doing that
and then he said
if you keep your money in the bank and
if you hold it in lyria's rather than
dollars i will make up
any difference you lose versus the
dollar you have to put it on deposit for
three months six months nine months but
if you do this then but if you hold in
there then you don't have to worry about
foreign currency losses because we'll
make it up to you but let's think about
what that means so
now the
someone had let's pretend somebody had a
hundred thousand dollars in dollars in a
turkish bank
and everyone says well you can't take it
out but and now you need to convert it
to lira okay so now he takes the dollars
gives it to the central bank and then
the central bank gives lira to this this
deposit this depositor okay so now he
has a lira instead of the the
depositorized layer so now let's say the
dollar rises 10
versus the the lira okay so now that
that that investor that depositor should
actually have a hundred and ten thousand
dollars so the way erdogan makes it up
to him is he is he prints another ten
thousand dollars of lyra
and puts it in the account
so basically what he's doing is you're
again the you're increasing the supply
of lyra eventually that's going to so
he's kind of working against
what he's trying to accomplish he's
trying to keep the the lyra strong but
he's actually instituting policies that
will make it weak um eventually um you
know
and so far the market has believed them
and they've done it they've kept their
money in there but eventually you know
inflation is going to go even higher
he's going to have to print even more
lyra and then you know at some point
people are going to say i just don't
trust this guy anymore i don't believe
this and they're and they're going to go
to the bank and they're going to try to
pull all their deposits and there's not
going to be enough money for everybody
and so then there'll be others run on
the bank and they'll be social
there'll be riots and they'll be you
know the food prices will be
skyrocketing so they'll be pissed off
about that so that those are the types
of things that you will see and again
everyone will come out and say this is
the work of the evil international
speculators or whoever he'll blame it on
somebody else right he won't take
responsibility for it so those are the
those are the types of things you need
to look for
when you think about uh the current
situation the federal reserve obviously
uh switching course from a super loose
monetary policy basically pumped asset
prices threw all this liquidity into the
market uh since um you know really kind
of global financial crisis but let's say
2020 when they you know kind of took it
on steroids uh starting in november they
started talking tough earlier this year
they start to raise interest rates uh
the market is pricing in 10 interest
rate increases this year
300 basis point interest rate by the end
of the year uh given this kind of i'll
call it a geopolitical
and potential sovereign crisis backdrop
can the fed continue to increase
interest rates and conduct quantitative
tightening uh or what is your
expectation what the fed actually will
be able to do given kind of the
complexity of the global game
yeah so i don't think they're going to
get 10 hikes in now i always say i never
rule anything out
and i'll give you an example at the end
of two that you know after the global
financial crisis they did extremely
loose monetary policy for years right
they raised interest rates one at the
end of 2015 and didn't do it again for
two years
and then everybody said they're never
going to be able to do it again but then
they did it and everybody said never
gonna be able to do it again and you
know what they did eight more hikes so
i didn't think they'd be able to do it
but they did it so that's one thing you
know nothing is certain no matter
there's so many people that are just
absolutely certain that they know how
this is all going to play out and to me
it's one of the most uncertain times in
history so so first of all don't be
certain about anything but that said i i
don't expect them to be able to get
eight or nine heights but i do expect
them to keep hiking until something
really breaks
and when i and and when i mean something
i don't mean stocks i don't think that
they care that stocks are down um partly
because stocks are still up like
60 70 from where they were at the
covered loads um you know i think in
january 2020 so two and a half years ago
i think stock prices were right around
where they're at now
so
you know
stocks went up a lot they've come back
but they haven't crashed from where they
were two years ago
and i think the fed is okay with asset
price inflation coming down if it also
helps them try at least to quash
consumer price inflation i think part of
the you know part of their main goal
here is to squash inflationary pressures
i think
the one of the biggest knocks against
the biden administration is they haven't
done enough for the little guy or main
street to fight these inflationary
pressures
and so you know there's an election
coming up in the fall and biden clearly
would like to have a democratic congress
rather than a republican congress to
work with and so i think he needs to be
seen to be helping the little guy as
opposed to the rich wall streeter or the
elites or however you want to define
that right so i think their number one
goal is to get inflation under control
got to come election time or at least
try
and i think
they don't necessarily mind equity
prices going lower but they would mind
very much if funding markets seized up
so if the credit market started to break
um if yield spreads started to really
widen if if companies or
or entities could no longer
fund their their debt service that would
be the time i think that the fed would
come in
and would uh would would reverse course
so to speak but i i don't think they're
going to do that i think they're going
to hold out longer than many people
think now
at the end of the day my job is not to
be right my job's to make money so
if i'm wrong that's fine i'll have to
pivot and be ready for it and you know
i'm kind of prepared for anything i
think that they're going to hike i think
they're going to continue i think
they'll get more off than many people
think they will but ultimately it will
break and we'll be back to um you know
reversing course but the point i would
make is this won't happen in a vacuum
what's not going to happen is that the
us isn't going to reverse course and go
into a big recession and things are
going to be beautiful in brazil and
things are going to be beautiful in
canada and things are going to be
awesome in turkey and things are going
to be incredible in russia we're not
going to have a situation where the u.s
goes into a massive recession and the
rest of the world is okay
um again never say never but that is
about the lowest probability event i can
think of
talk to me about how you're allocating
capital today right when we talked back
in 2020 what's changed in the portfolio
and kind of how do you think about
positioning yourself for this potential
scenario uh that i would say that you
know you're optimistic uh maybe not from
like a positive you want it to happen
but you think it's going to happen so
how are you allocating capital and
what's the portfolio look like
well from a uh
from a thesis perspective haven't
changed the
how i want to the exposures have changed
a little bit we have more cash now than
we did then um
well i should say
i can't remember exactly when we spoke
anthony if we spoke in february of 2020
i probably positioned pretty similarly
if if we spoke in may or june it was
like may or june i think okay so then i
probably you know i probably am more
hedged now than i was then
um so we
the the portfolios that i managed we
managed separately managed accounts and
a lot of my clients have had for 10 15
some cases 20 years
so we've owned equities for all of that
time and so typically when we reduce
exposure to equities we don't
necessarily sell them a lot of times
we'll hedge them so we've been not fully
hedged but heavily hedged
on our equity exposure all year but we
still own equities
you know we have a couple years ago we
dramatically reduced our duration in
fixed income and so now we own
short-term fixed income um now that that
hasn't made any money in fact it's down
a little bit year-to-date but it hasn't
gotten smoked the way you know a 10-year
bond or a 30-year bond house so that's
kind of a cash substitute so we have uh
hedged equities uh higher levels of cash
than we typically do short-term fixed
income uh we have allocations to real
estate we have out in in our stock
portfolios we have a heavy allocation to
agriculture and energy
so those positions have done well um
all clients
we not all not all of them have done it
but we heavily recommend that every
of our clients hold gold
and again you know i'd say the the
average allocation in our portfolios are
anywhere from five to twenty percent
um
and then uh we have an allocation of
volatility and the volatility you know
uh did not the volatility allocation
over the last two years was not done
well at all uh because there hasn't been
much um
but the rest of the portfolio did well
now this year to date uh the volatility
portfolio is doing better because we've
got volatility again and i expect that
volatility to continue kind of for the
rest of the year and into the next
couple years
last thing i want to talk about is uh is
bitcoin and you talked about gold i know
that you've been uh um heavily
allocating and i'll say heavily just
that five to twenty percent range that
you just described what are your
thoughts on bitcoin today do you uh
recommend it to clients do clients buy
it do you think it's absolutely trash
like what's the general thought process
well
i wouldn't say that i recommend it i
think you you know that i'm kind of
skeptical of it um
and
but that said i i have clients who are
very interested in it and uh i have
helped them buy it and so some some of
my clients own bitcoin and i help them
think about it and you know how much and
where and with who and all of that kind
of stuff
um
you know i i i've long had a problem
with bitcoin because i've long had a
problem with the stablecoin market right
and you know specifically my issue has
been with tether
now we haven't really seen
um the dramatic dramatics play out in
the tether market but we did see them
have played out pretty significantly and
some other stable coins um and so that
if if if we could kind of get
and i know a lot of people think this is
fun and bryn just needs to get over it
but you know i i feel like the tether is
kind of the euro dollar market for for
the crypto world and it permeates all
the different institutions and entities
and exchanges and
until that gets resolved for me it would
be really hard for me to
to to go hard into something like
bitcoin now the other thing i'll say is
philosophically i love bitcoin and and i
don't have any problem with investing
their own money in bitcoin right um as a
fiduciary i i can't tell somebody go put
100 of your money into bitcoin uh even
if i did
like that i would never say that cause i
don't think that's the right thing to do
um
but i i think
the other thing that i have been worried
about with bitcoin and i think error
crypto however you want a digital aspect
however you want to define this space
how do you define it by the way what's
the right way for me to say this because
a lot of times i'll say crypto and
they'll say but bitcoin isn't crypt
though yeah what do i say how do i refer
to the whole industry
depends on who you ask i think the way
at least the way i look at it is bitcoin
is very much uh digital sound money it's
trying to be a currency whether you
think it's a good currency or not uh so
store value medium exchange eventually
unit of account uh there's a lot of
other things that aren't trying to be
currencies so they may be trying to be
you know the equivalent of equities or
commodities or whatever and so i think
that's where you hear people say hey
it's bitcoin and crypto uh it's really
just once trying to you know essentially
rise and be the global reserve currency
uh with this programmatic monetary
policy and then everything else is
taking you know commodities uh or
equities et cetera and just trying to
put it on to a blockchain
got it so so my my other
worry or criticism however whatever the
right way to define that is is that the
powers that be
will crack down on it now it doesn't
mean that they will be successful i
happen to think that they will be more
successful than a lot of other people
but i think we're starting to see that
you know we're you're starting to see
more and more uh monetary authorities
come out and say it needs to be
regulated we need to think about this
the the little people have gotten hurt
now don't get me wrong there's other
you know uh governmental agencies and
entities that are trying to promote
bitcoin you know we just had the you
know this thing down in el salvador last
week with a number of you know central
bankers from some smaller countries
meeting with uh
bouquet about uh how they've instituted
their uh bitcoin policy i just i
ultimately think that it's going to be a
much harder
game for
bitcoin advocates
than they think i think the government
has a lot more tricks up their sleeve
than they do i think they'll be more
successful
regulating it squashing it however how
again however you want to define that
um
that said you know i i just i love the
idea i really do i would love it if we
had the ability to choose whichever
currency that we wanted to use
um
i don't think that that's a reality you
know for much of history you didn't get
to choose what your currency was
typically the local power whether it's a
president or a prime minister or a you
know warlord whatever it is they they
the king they say what money is and then
they enforce it and
you know while as much as i might like
you know the freedom of to choose you
very rarely in history if you had the
freedom to choose what your money was
and and i just i think we're actually
going towards an area era of
centralization rather than
decentralization i know decentralization
is the big uh the big push the big want
and i agree i would love a decentralized
world i don't think that's going to
happen or at least i don't think it's
going to happen yet so
um anyway for all those reasons i have i
i don't recommend bitcoin yeah i am i
actually think that uh hearing you kind
of talk a little bit more about it and
some of the nuance of your thought
process is that you and the bitcoin
community actually see eye to eye right
i think that the bitcoin community would
actually argue like hey the world is
going towards centralization uh they're
all all these things that you're
describing like they very much like yes
agreed agreed agreed and they're just
kind of shaking their head yes uh maybe
where there there is a difference of
opinion is more so what do we do about
it right and i think that ultimately uh
there's two things you can do about it
one is you can basically say hey i
believe the world's going to play out
this way and therefore i'm going to
position myself uh via legacy assets to
benefit from it or kind of be protected
and i know how to do that frankly i have
the expertise and skill set and
experience to do it and i think the
bitcoin answer is like hey the average
person has no clue what's going on
they're going to get absolutely racked
here and like a decentralized
programmatic monetary policy ends up
being the solution because they can use
as a savings account uh i don't know
similar to your point like i don't know
which one ends up being the right answer
but i think that uh it's kind of like
gold i always say that uh the gold bugs
and the bitcoiners
95 of the argument they see eye to eye
and they're like there's all these
problems in the legacy system this is
really bad like people are going to get
hurt et cetera and then when they get to
the end of like okay what's the solution
gold uh folks are like oh it's physical
analog sound money and the bitcoin is
like oh but with this digital version
right and so like they're actually both
even saying that sound money is the
solution it's just two different assets
i agree so so let me let me tell you one
of the other things that is frustrating
not frustrating that's not the right way
to say it what
the the the okay
the thing that i think that is most
helpful in my opinion about bitcoin and
and the rise of crypto
is it has helped educate an entirely new
generation of people
about money about what it is how
governments influence it the the pros
the cons a lot of cons right
um and i think that's a very good thing
and the more people the problem is is
that typically the people the sound
money people
typically have not had a lot of capital
if you you know
that's just the reality typically the
the money changers the keynesians those
are the people that are running things
and they have
political power because they have
monetary power
this is an opportunity where a lot of
people who now have sound money um ideas
have made a killing have made an
incredible amount of money the amount of
wealth that's been created a lot of it's
been lost recently but the amount of
money that's been created is incredible
and
i
when i hear people who have made an
incredible amount of money
and they still have all of their money
or 98 of it and they're encouraging
other people to put all of their money
into this
arena i would very much like them to
sell a little bit put it off to the side
make sure they never have to go work for
the man again
right i mean once you've had money once
you've had independence the last thing
you ever want to do is go work for
somebody else again so make sure you
don't have to do it
sell something
put it in gold you know
you have experience you you've uh you've
been doing this longer you've seen
cycles there there is uh there's an
education process and i think what
you're describing is where most
bitcoiners are going to end up uh i've
got a friend jason williams who he says
like hey you may want a couch you may
want a mattress you may want some chairs
in your home right like like you need a
car like there's some things that you
need not only in from an investment
standpoint but also just like enjoy your
life as well
yeah and that's it
if you want to try to change the world
it's totally fine i respect it go for it
you know if you die storming the castle
at least you lived a good life i
understand it
but but when you say you cannot possibly
lose i'm going to argue with you right
i'm not going to accept the fact that
you cannot possibly lose
no but nobody has a guarantee to win it
just doesn't work that way
um and so i think you know i i i
i have tried to use
my my uh interactions with the bitcoin
community to just bring a little bit of
of experience right a little bit of
sense a little bit of common sense just
you know don't bet at all and if you do
bet at all that's fine but you know be
very careful encouraging other people to
bet at all because
it might not work out anyway i'll just
leave it with that brent
anytime you want to come tell uh tell a
message to the bitcoin community you're
more than welcome here i uh i tend to
think that uh uh your view on the world
is obviously one nuance but also two
uh i i i have to say that and i've told
people this privately but but uh feels
important to tell you is i respect that
you've had an opinion you've been very
clear so here here's how i think the
world's gonna play out uh and at times
it looks like it's going in the
direction you thought and at times
frankly it looks like it was trading
kind of a way and uh you're one of the
rare people who you just said look
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm not i don't
know but like i still think this thing
and uh you know sitting here today looks
a little bit different than it did in
the middle of you know 2020 right and so
i think that uh uh it's pretty
commendable um how uh how how you've
done that so i just one i appreciate it
but also too uh i think that uh you and
the bitcoin crowd you agree on more than
you disagree on which is actually uh
pretty cool to see
well
i appreciate you saying that the thing
i'll leave on is you know i think over
the last couple years
you know there's been a number of
different issues whether it's bitcoin
whether it's covid whether it's
government politics war religion there's
all these you know there's all these
different issues that are dividing us
and man i i'm never going to stop
talking to people even if they
completely disagree with me even if they
hate me even if i think they're idiots
even if they think i'm an idiot i'm not
going to stop talking to them just
because i totally disagree with them and
i think that's how really bad things
happen so i would encourage everybody to
keep an open mind talk to everybody
don't shut anybody out you know just
try to try to try to keep it fairly
civilized
and throw a few punches here and there
but just keep it civilized
i love it where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find more
about santiago
um so i have a landing page with really
just my contact information at
santiagocapital.com you can reach me via
that um you know i'm pretty active on
twitter if you type in santiago capital
in the search engine you'll find it
um you know you can go to youtube or
google and type in either santiago
capital or dollar milkshake theory and
you'll get more links than you know to
do with um
so yeah i think that's probably the best
way my friend that twitter bio is
amazing milkshake man
that is incredible i think so somebody
somebody else derogatorily uh referred
to me as that so i just thought i'd
adopt it and make it positive that's the
best way to handle the trolls is just
say yep you're right thank you
appreciate it move on uh all right well
thank you so much for doing this and
we'll definitely do it again as as kind
of everything continues to play out but
i appreciate your time sounds great